I everybody, I’m Jordan Auten, the producer
and co-director of the short film GRIT and
I’m here to guide you through the Must Do’s
of producing your own SAG short film.
1.
Start with the Script.
Before you get started, you want to have a
really great script.
What story are you telling and what message
are you sending to the world?
For example with our film GRIT, when I read
the script, I knew it was something I wanted
to direct and produce because it was really
witty, it was really funny and because it
was an inspiring story about women, choice
and motherhood.
As a filmmaker, those are the types of stories
I want to put in the world, have a story that
aligns with your vision as a filmmaker.
2.
Production Team.
Next you’ll want to secure your production
team.
You must have a producer who is resourceful
and thorough when researching the rules and
guidelines within the SAG process.
Ask your filmmaker friends for recommendations
for production people.
Our budget allows a production team with a
producer, co-producer and a production manager.
3.
Paperwork.
Next you’ll want to file your SAG paperwork.
In order to produce a SAG project you must
have a qualified signatory who produces the
film.
Your producer can be the signatory or you
can create a separate business like an LLC
or a DBA.
You’ll want to consult a lawyer or a tax
professional as to the pros and cons of each.
Keep in mind that whomever ends up being the
SAG signatory will technically own the rights
to the film once it’s complete.
Take the time to learn the difference between
a short film contract and the new media contract
and decide what’s best for your production.
(Hint: It will depend on what you choose for
your primary distribution.)
4.
Workman’s Comp.
Purchase workman’s compensation insurance
for your production.
SAG requires for your talent to be covered
and it’s very important.
5.
Payroll.
Hire a payroll company for your cast.
SAG has specifics you want to follow when
it comes to following all of the union fees
and ensure everyone’s safety.
6.
Final Thoughts.
I highly recommend you get to know the SAG
rules regarding short films and create a professional
working environment for everyone on set.
Have an amazing shoot and happy shooting.